foreign
people welcome to another hot and fresh
Honest Trailers commentaries uh released
in the doldrums of January oh boy we've
got a lot to look forward to but this
week it's Snakes on a Plane um
I'm here with Lon and Danielle of course
this is an homage to the Gerard Butler
movie plane that came out this week as
you all as you all figured out okay
we were debating whether we're just
gonna do money playing again but uh too
cheeky um we should have uh we should
gone with money playing or we should
have like halfway through this one been
like you know what I'm not even into
this anymore let's get back to money
playing already in progress and that one
would have worked too because the Royal
Rumble is on Saturday oh why didn't we
do it why didn't we do airplane [__] we
should have just done an airplane oh
well why because airplanes funny and
it's yeah because airplane's funny it's
it's they're they're already doing it oh
well anyways we're gonna watch Snakes on
a Plane uh we're gonna talk about the
things we cut out we'll show you uh
we'll take your questions put those in
the chat and then we'll tease you with a
surprise uh a release for next week that
we're yeah we're mixing it up we're
pretty excited for uh like a last second
audible yeah
um so good movies are on the horizon but
this week snakes in a plane
totally shocked we'd never you would
have thought at some point in the last
decade plus of honest trailers they we
wouldn't have gotten it would have you
would have thought like there'd be a Sam
Jackson thing or an airplane thing or a
snake thing if there's a snake thing
we're doing it we're doing Anaconda um
because that's that's a gem
um yeah regardless I had never seen this
movie
um oh no I feel like Anaconda would make
us better well Anaconda holds something
better
it was terrible it's terrible it's not
terrible because it's
well okay it's terrible in the way that
it not in the way that like an asylum
film is terrible yes right and but it's
not good either
um no it's it's like it's terrible but
it's not terrible enough yeah in a way I
I have very kind of terrible yeah I have
rules for what makes a bad movie good
but I kind of like stick through and I
think that like one of the most
important
things that makes a bad movie like
camp and worth watching and interesting
is it like it can't be that it was meant
to be a bad movie it has to be made with
sincerity and there's no sincerity in
this this is just literally like you
know uh 20 you know 2006 memes like the
version of a 2006 meme yeah it is like
disaster movie start but starring Sam
Jackson like the fact that he he goes in
there and
it's a kind of winking commitment but
just to see him do like a feature-length
sketch of Sam Jackson uh on a plane with
snakes I I found it more entertaining
than other movies like this it's right I
feel like I wish it would have either
just been what either one just either
direction instead of trying to be like
yeah well you could make like a good bad
movie like no you can't do that you
can't go in thinking that there there
was it was gonna be more of like a move
like a regular Thriller in an airplane
like a movie like a movie like a
suspense like a real movie like a proper
move
and then but Samuel Jackson was like no
it's got to be more of a b movie and so
there was already this kind of behind
the scenes section and then the internet
came along it was like we're making this
a meme and a joke and so you can really
feel that tension in the movie and I'm
sorry whoever were the people on the
creative team who were like no we got to
take this seriously and make it a real
movie like I hope none of them ever
worked again because Samuel Jackson was
right
he they should have just listened to him
from the beginning he had the right idea
it should have been a goofy joke the
whole time the fact that you could feel
them try to pull back like well we
should really explain the the black
market snake dealer that got them the
snakes and where the snakescape are like
well we should really I mean I think
that's a good Instinct they just could
have made that more fun and Goofy
instead of just like a generic bad guy
right it's the total tonal mismatch
between like real movie and then goofy
internet joke and like why is it even
trying to be a real movie it's so stupid
be a flat out parody instead of trying
to be like oh we're gonna make a cult
classic you can't go into something and
be like we're gonna make a cult classic
like right that's like trying to make a
new Coke you don't have control yeah
because it's like even like Sharknado
like though they know what they're doing
it's consistent movies but if you are a
fan like that it's it's a consistent
experience it knows it's a Sharknado
movie from start to
[Laughter]
yeah you know it's a tornado with sharks
I understand the premise
I mean I enjoyed Sam Jackson's scenes I
just I just did I felt like do you
remember that um I don't know if it ever
came out in America but that like improv
show where uh an actor walks into a set
and it's uh like full of actors and like
a scene that they've never walked into
before and then they improvised from
there
I feel like they took Sam Jackson like
he walked onto a set and it was an
airplane full of snakes and then like he
he you know went back to what he's most
comfortable with which is just yelling
instructions the top of his lungs
airplane full of snakes and um I had a
good enough time with that and then I do
think this was also entertaining to me
seeing it in 2023 as like an early 2000s
Time Capsule that kind of kept me
entertained for sure
um so let's watch it all together uh
let's take uh throw on your jinkos
actually my arrows are all mixed up what
did you wear in the early 2000s probably
your tight jeans uh and then let's watch
Snapchat yeah no jingos were gone by
then trying to remember if I had a
crotch pocket in 2006 and I did not
put your drugs because they couldn't get
girls above the knee
[Music]
from the studio who released Lord of the
Rings and still lost money that year and
a director who's been trying to get
animals on plane since his debut
Comes A B movie that delivers exactly
what it promises in the title Snakes on
a Plane snakes check plane check
in 2000 so pause
um not much we can do from there I can't
really add to that I'm already honest
about it yeah and there's a whole uh
thing in interviews where Sam Jackson's
talked about how they wanted to change
the title to like flight 147 or
something and he's like no 6-12 or like
some generic plane move like plane
basically yeah
no no way
um but then the director's explanation
for that was they were having a hard
time getting real actors to audition for
something called Snakes on a Plane so
they retitled they retitled it in like
the casting call to get people to show
up for like a real Disaster Movie and
not Snakes on a Plane so there's your
background it's like passenger 57 or
like that yeah I really worked for a
long time when I try to come up
come up and do a 57 pun for this I said
I'd never really never really got 50
Venoms say snakes like there's like that
the the doofy I've always been under
transporting I was like passenger 50
Kevin
the closer that was as close which
apparently Kevin's a slur in Germany I
didn't know and uh France yeah wait for
what what does it mean it just means
like uh Kevin is like a a name for like
a stupid person and so apparently
someone on Twitter this week was like I
didn't know that Kevin was just an
actual name you named people outside of
Germany although they could be playing
one of those delightful German pranks
that my people yeah and it's in in
um well first of all shout out to her
yeah shout out to our editor Uh Kevin
Williamson very talented and Brightman
um but uh it's the cabin to the world
yeah it's so weird I thought in France
it means like you're kind of like a it's
like a hick name like
um
Cletus yeah I'm looking at there's this
New Yorker article how Kevin's got a bad
rap in France so that's your that's your
supplementary reading for today's
Australia commentary we love you Kevin
not all of you probably I mean there is
one we need to talk
um
yeah
let's move on I'm just thinking about
different Kevin's
in 2006. fans convinced new line Cinema
that Snakes on a Plane was gonna be a
Smash Hit cranking out early internet
memes launching blogs and turning their
suggestions into reshoots until it
finally came out and proved for the
first time that the online weirdo
audience may be smaller than it appears
yeah so pause this was like an early
morbius situation yeah everyone was like
we're gonna see this movie and then it
came out and they said no we're not nope
we're gonna pirate this movie I I went
during opening weekend to see this I saw
this in theaters when it opened and
there was it was a packed house when I
saw it on like the Saturday night when I
saw it and you could feel in the room
like when the movie passed the 12 minute
Mark or so you could feel everyone
coming to the collective realization
that we'd waste did our time like oh
it's not gonna be fun like this isn't
gonna be one of the like you kind of
went in thinking it was going to be like
an RR thing like we were gonna joke and
dance and laugh together and it was
gonna be this great communal experience
and then right away it becomes obvious
that it's just not that kind of movie
and it's not really working and I
remember there's that moment where
Samuel Jackson goes everybody we got to
put a barrier between us and the snakes
and the mistakes and that was in like
all the trailers it was an internet meme
at the time and a guy yelled it out with
Samuel L Jackson no reaction
it just sank on delivery and we were all
like yeah we're just now we're now we're
all sitting in this together for the
next hour like this is not going to be
the new like uh Rocky Horror right
everybody thought it was going to be
this like big like we were all going to
the Minions movie in our suits and it
just didn't
the issue is though that I feel like in
this case the fans had the right
instincts because apparently what they
were pushing for was like make it more
of a schlocky movie they added the MF or
line like at fans requests yeah it
should have been all that from the
beginning why are you ever trying to
tell a real story about Snakes on a
Plane you that that's not a good story
you know what I'm realizing it needed
when you're talking about like RR and
stuff like that it's like you needed a
rival snake you needed Sam Jackson and
like a snake friendly snake snake sure
but it's missing a villain outside of
the general concept of snakes and planes
what you needed was like of like a
personal connection to like that's the
Snake That Killed my partner and it's
the king snake like this is the worst
snake I need like a final showdown
between me and this one like a Meg snake
right when we were doing the Meg and we
were like how could you make this move
be and not have Jason Statham like fight
the shark like obviously we want to see
Jason Statham fight a shark
yeah right I feel like you're exactly
right that it needs to be Samuel Jackson
fighting snakes and there's one there's
one shot where he grabs a snake and just
whips it against the side of the plane
and it's like more or less I want way
more snake food and way less like
generic Disaster Movie like we gotta go
here we gotta hop now the plane's
breaking down yeah and it's very yeah I
mean Samuel L Jackson had a partner that
was on the plane that had been his dude
that he'd been ride or die with for
years so they could have had that beat
that like when that like big huge you
know anaconda or whatever comes out
kills his partner he's like and like
yeah becomes like his like breaking
point and it becomes now it's personal
and you need the Final Duel at the end
anyways we'll we'll rewrite next next
week
um
before he testifies and he's not leaving
anything to chance smuggling a bomb onto
his plane and blowing it up to release a
bunch of snakes to release a bunch of
snakes because when you want to leave no
Witnesses you Wrangle 400 deadly snakes
from a third party in Los Angeles only
one guy could arrange this many illegal
snakes have those snakes shipped to
Honolulu rig their cage act with
explosives ship those snakes back to Los
Angeles bring on an inside man at the
airport to tip you off on which plane to
Target employ different guys to load the
actual snakes under the plane and soak
the passengers legs with pheromones hire
another person to break into the plane
and open an access panel ahead of time
somebody rigged this access panel door
to stay open so the snakes could get out
all I should be shooting this over the
airport or just spiking his Red Bull you
know all those security scenarios we ran
I'm smacking the middle one we didn't
think of because the old snake thing is
insane
um also one thing uh Lon pointed out
that uh I hope cinemason's got it too is
uh yeah they don't give you lays when
you leave Hawaii back to Los Angeles
that would just be uncomfortable to sit
on a plane for six hours with a bunch of
flowers on on a red eye to LAX menu yeah
and then you like take it off and you do
all your touristy stuff you know down in
Waikiki
um you know you go visit the various ABC
Stores which are basically the Starbucks
of Hawaii
um also you're not just gonna sit with a
wet lay on for like six hours this one
smells like like it smells like snake
come yeah
two snakes get it on spray the pheromone
in the cabin you don't need them to be
hidden on the like what do you what are
you doing what are you doing Eddie
he said he had no other option the kids
saw him also you can't just oh first of
all it also very much seems that they
added in like two
to three excess minutes of extreme dirt
biking but also the kid's an extreme
dirt biker you don't have to go to his
house wait till the next time that he's
biking on dirt and then you just like
oh nature and then he calls and he dies
and it's like oh yeah it's like tragic
dirt bike accident right you know about
this movie which is here as a time
capsule one thing that was fun about
2006 is they keep doing that like the
fight club like push the camera through
the boxes of snakes like CG you know
like like animation like we're gonna
drop through the levels of the plane to
the lowest level and see where the bomb
is and then go up through the floor and
it's like it doesn't look good but in
2006 we were still like oh no folks we
love it really do that yeah yeah yeah
um should have saved the money first or
rubber snakes
yeah all right keep going there's some
of the deadliest creatures on Earth they
can attack without warning really I
never
and one has just been Unleashed 30 000
feet in the air a Samuel L Jackson
protagonist
[Music]
FBI agent Neville Flynn is a bad
[__]
if you're watching it on cable TV I have
had it with these monkey fighting snakes
on this Monday to Friday play he's here
to save the days Sam Jackson protagonist
knows how yelling we have to put a
barrier between us and the snakes let's
go everybody move forward consciously
cautiously
what was the first thing
and it's a good thing he does because
this close door isn't bringing much to
the table that's great
have fun
you ready for this
congratulations Nathan Phillips you are
the same Worthington of jai courtneys
Flynn hey they got they got a snake guy
on the phone
first of all right this is the thing
I've mentioned that we had talked about
this should have been a speed and he his
character should have been Sandra
Bullock uh and that would have made this
entire movie like well I feel like
Keenan should have been Sandra Bullock
because like I've I'm the guy who
learned how to fly from a FL from a
video game like my I'm I now have to
keep the plane going because like you
could have killed off
though yeah no he's like he's playing
with Keenan yeah he's playing Keenan um
flying back from SNL vacation or
whatever
um yeah that dude that dude and this was
an influential movie in a lot of in a
lot of ways because that guy is one of
the many and I didn't realize how many
there are Australian hunks who play
generic white action heroes oh yeah oh
my God a long proud life that's why I
said Sam Worthington Jay Courtney
um all the hemsworths uh there's so many
until he learned how to act right there
was um Edgerton right Joel yes yes
that's what I was trying to think of
yeah um Australian
um
yeah Eric Bana Charlie Hunnam that is
amazing because Eric Bana was a stand-up
comedian in Australia he was not like
wild too much I can't even I gotta
that's I gotta look that up it was only
like he came over here and you know
smoldering good looks became like a
romantic lead yeah that's amazing yeah
also uh what's his name the dude he was
in all of the zenas and the Hercules and
then
um he did he did some Star Treks and
some marbles and I can't think of his
name right off the top but he's either
Australia oh I don't don't say that
video oh no they're gonna eat me up in
the comments he's either Australian or
New Zealand I'm so sorry
oh they're gonna oh they're gonna murder
me just made a uh I just uh that's what
they call an unforced error that was an
unforced ERA but yeah no he was in a um
the new one with the Zachary Quinto and
it's gonna bother me now so I like have
to look it up or I'm gonna die not Eric
better who was actually also in that
um
Carl Urban is transcendent though I
think uh these are these are just kind
of lunky dudes that don't once you
become once you become dread you're in a
category yeah yeah you've reached Escape
philosophy I fell in love with him on
Xena and Hercules so nice nice I didn't
even know he was from from the ocean
yeah I'll show you Clips
all right let's keep going entire
cabin's worth of hacky stereotypes like
fake share from Clueless played by an
actual fake share from Clueless a
germaphobic rapper who seems a lot more
relatable now after kovid
me and coughing on me it's disgusting up
in here Tina the turtle of his Entourage
a couple on their honeymoon kids
traveling alone snooty Brit from first
class Herbie pilot old veteran who dies
one month short of retirement horny
teenagers salty nuns old women who speak
Jive and Kareem Abdul-Jabbar oh wait I
was thinking of airplane again can we
just watch airplane again and that as
much as anything else led to my drinking
problem
[Laughter]
did any characters kind of transcend the
the complete hack back of the napkin
stereotype uh for you I mean we all love
Keenan uh he was trying he was doing he
was he was yeah he was the the very best
that I think you could possibly do with
this material I did it is funny to spot
like you know a few of the people who
play those like background care like
Taylor Kitsch is one of the best friends
I did not catch that the first time uh
so like that's fun but no it's it's
really it's really like hacky and thin
the whole like everybody's got like a
dumb bit you know like and it just it's
like it's that kind of mean-spirited
like 80s comedy you know where it's like
everybody's like a mean stereotype
they're all like dumb or horny or like
idiots yeah yeah like no snobs yeah it's
all just like this put down kind of
insult unfriendly black hotties like
yeah I will say that for
um as snooty as the British guy was I
think if you're on a red eye you get
bumped from first class and then put in
a middle seat between a baby and a dog
you're gonna be a little bit snooty yeah
I understand Julianna Margulies being
like this flight you know like it's that
they're asking a lot of their uh their
flight attendance but you know what's
great is that the movie correctly
predicted that the offense for that is
murder yep that's right you you get
eaten by a snake you are rude snake eats
your head be polite
um okay let's keep going just back to
the naughty Oris for a Creature Feature
that's pretty self-aware that's good
news snakes on crack but most of the
time feels like something Beavis and
Butthead would come up with on the couch
what I'm like the airplane toilet I have
to sneak inside you know when you went
to pee on it like video in the wiener oh
yeah yeah like this hot chick takes her
clothes off in there and like a snake
Pops at him bite them
yeah and then like a snake bites someone
in their butt that'd be cool
story The hateful Freight witness for
the prosecution the good flight Paris
Texas Hilton threesomes
um Paris Texas that's a good movie it is
a good movie I just wanted to bring that
up just as long as we're if you're
looking for a good movie to watch try
that one yeah can't can't complain uh I
will also say I am DB says there are two
cameos in this film yeah I couldn't find
them Harris Hilton and then another
gentleman who I don't think we need to
to shout out uh I didn't see either of
them I didn't see either of them they're
clear analogies for them as these
characters right but yeah they're not I
wonder if it's like there was a version
of the script where they were just like
I'm just gonna put in the name of the
person that this should be and we'll
change it later absolutely untrue like
that is something funny in there later
yeah by the way this would be so much
better if they used the real Paris
Hilton in there yeah
and she was acting around then why not
yeah
and the naughty era yeah
wow uh keep going
grierson.com
Elsa Pataki playing a new mom whose baby
is in extreme Danger on a plane part one
of two Tim Hawkins Cobra Commander
and snake vision goggles a lot of this
like
the snakes
love snake Vision this is the best the
best decision they made in the entire
movie
honestly make me uh now you won't smoke
snakes in a plane is a perfect title but
just for fun
black snake float
reptile wins
10 points for Slytherin
Monty pythons flying
you know I feel like this airplane is
about to crash no matter what in any one
of those slimy little pieces can trip a
circuit or a relay or hydraulic and this
bird goes down faster than a tie hooker
yeah I was amazed how vulnerable an
airplane was to snakes I feel like if
You released a box no matter how many uh
of snakes in the in the cargo hold of an
airplane they would not bring the whole
thing crashing down I mean sure panic
but like they wouldn't chew through the
airplane unless it's Spirit Airlines
you know a bottle of coke would chew
through that
yeah it's oh you you don't want to be
poisoned by a snake that is an extra
twelve dollars that'll be yeah that's
that's 12 you got to pay an extra 12 fee
to not get bitten that's a snake thing
it's on there yeah these look at this
low low price point snakes can bite
[Laughter]
and if you say no they just spray you
with the anger hormone yeah
that's no pillow
those snakes think it was just an orgy
happening and they're like why do all
these people keep stopping our orgy I'm
just trying to get in there from the
snake's perspective this was yeah just a
big uh misunderstanding
I thought she wanted it they thought
they were going to an Eyes Wide Shut
party and then all of a sudden Samuel
Jackson is yelling at them shooting him
with a harpoon that's my wife like I
didn't I didn't know the house password
they didn't tell me I left my keys in
the bulk
so yeah a bit of a missed opportunity
could have been better
um but decent enough uh a real filler
film
um both in itself and for Honest
Trailers because boy we have fun stuff
coming up Don't worry
um and thank you for watching because
you're the real ones if you're watching
the commentary for Snakes on a Plane
welcome to Welcome to the party pal this
is this is the real Clubhouse uh print
out a cool merit badge for yourself that
you watch this video
uh and I'd say like And subscribe and
hit the Bell but if you're watching this
you already do
um so thank you yeah these are the
hardcores thank you for joining us again
and uh let's see if there's any outtakes
that the online weirdo audience may be
smaller than it appears but it won't be
the last time a studio makes that
mistake definitely not the last time
story window seat unsnakeable
Samuel L Jackson's son phony Hawk just a
teenage dirt bike baby the morning show
heiress share Horowitz three his Mafia
or Phoebe biggie crawls or Splat Keenan
and well gamer great canceled pilot Todd
tracker the s-files special agent Harris
John Harder
oh well cool there's a badass looking
kickboxer on board can't wait to watch
him fight some snakes with his
kickboxing skills wait no not even one
time then why would you bring that up at
all
terrible let's send them to movie jail
for that if you have a character in the
in the First Act this is chekhov's
kickboxer and he's like he's like got
like a cool scar on his face and he's
kind of a little beat up he's wearing a
tank top and they're like I'm a
kickboxer I'm gonna take my seat now hey
man that man needs to kickbox at some
point ah snake he needs to kick a snake
I think that we all know what needs to
happen and it doesn't happen it's just
like come on yeah it has to be a moment
where he is what stands between the
snakes and the baby he needs to be
kicking a lot of snake ass throughout
the thing and then to set up even bigger
the big snake that killed Sam Jackson's
partner he needs to lose the kickboxing
match at the end so it's like wow now
this is a really threatening snake Sam
Jackson's gonna have his hands full he's
gonna it's like you have to rely on
everything he learned along this journey
to take us none of these snakes has even
seen Bloodsport and it's really
embarrassing for them it's really
embarrassing
um
it's about to bring up Andrew Tate but
we don't need to but but how great would
it be to have him uh eaten by a snake in
this movie friends or bed bugs and lice
and snakes wow the podcast equipment
first yeah just Snakes on a
pods it's just eating everyone's podcast
equipment oh sounds amazing it's unsold
um all right so uh we have some great
questions rolling in let's let's dive
into those
um Pericles Dragon Ball Snakes on a
Plane is Infamous for the monkey
fighting snakes on this Monday to Friday
plain edit what's your favorite edited
line for television that's got to be
stranger in the Alps I think
French a stranger in the Alps yeah yeah
I don't really remember I know there
used to be a lot of really good examples
of this yeah and I don't really remember
a lot of them clearly yeah since I
watched I don't watch film on cable
anymore there is that great Mr show uh
sketch pallies do you remember this
where it's good Fellas but what if
Goodfellas
they actually like you know like so
Odenkirk is like flipping a guy off but
then they actually cut out a bit of the
screen and replace it with a thumbs up
it's really funny look it up Mr show
palies it was a great sort of Riff on
that boy I think um uh what's it called
Usual Suspects is like give me the keys
you Fairy Godmother that was pretty good
right yeah well because that one is such
a crucial line
scene yeah yeah
um but really I think that my favorite
thing are scenes that are um only in the
Chinese release of certain films like
Iron Man 3 where it's where he gets uh a
life-changing operation by um a team of
hard-working um mainland China doctors
then they're never that's it's just its
own little subplot of like wow thank you
Tony Stark or the other way around like
thank you John thank you for Chinese
doctors for saving me yeah
um hard to find hard to find that uh
that version um but it's out there uh
all right up in the Disney vaults yeah
let's see
um Evan J pretzer aside from Jackson
Ford or Cruz what actor or actress would
you want to yell at you on a plane while
trying to keep you alive
oh Butler I mean Butler's the inheritor
of this proud tradition I feel like at
this point yeah she butts he could do it
for sure yeah Ray Liotta is also in a
great uh like airplane disaster Thriller
turbulence so yeah not a lot of modern
turbulence but that was fun Viola Davis
would be a good yelling at you trying to
get you to get some stuff done yeah I
feel like Amanda Waller could be that
person like yeah he's got a team in the
air and she's barking at them
this is all great these are all too good
though
I think like Charlize Theron is a is a
step away from doing movies like this
um oh yeah sure she could definitely
yell her way through a Plane full of
snakes probably Liam Neeson also had his
memorable like commuting Series where he
did like eight eight movies that are
action movies in a rows that are various
forms of transportation yeah unknown the
passenger he's got a bunch of this is a
really thought-provoking one though so
so keep your keep your answers coming in
the chat I like this one a lot Wahlberg
I think would be another one that people
would people would know sure he's
probably he's got him he must have had
at least one air survival thing at this
point no Wahlberg
oh he saves it for real life
um yeah he's gonna stop 911. that's
where it was um that that uh that one um
red night City update Channel says what
film from the past would have benefited
from internet meme hype this is an
interesting one of like what would have
been the internet darling of like an 80s
or early 90s film where the fans would
have gone I mean obviously any Star Wars
sequel would have been crazy but they
didn't need it they didn't need the
internet can you can you imagine if
something like Deliverance came out
today like a a movie that really like
Deliverance interesting the 60s or 70s
like if that did they just dropped that
on unsuspecting internet fans in the 19
in the 2020s that'd be interesting yeah
because that one the the squeal like a
pig would have been like a crazy meme is
that like shocked America but you you
kind of had to see the movie that like
it wasn't just like everybody learned
about that on the same day like today
that would be like the trailer would
land and be like do you guys see this
this movie with uh huge like Adam Driver
and Chris Hemsworth are in it they run a
foul of some like Bayou people and you
know like it would just I I can't
imagine the reaction the internet would
have to that I think that uh Masters of
the Universe would be another one of
those where it's like the trade that
would be amorbius or would be like oh
we're all gonna go see Masters of the
Universe and like I think we have
something here we're going to re-release
it it's like no yeah we'll take we'll
take more Masters of the Universe fuel
though I think the the animated Lord of
the Rings people would have gone crazy
over then been furious at that it wasn't
you know like the Box enough yeah it's
also it's like all the stuff that that
already kind of went like 80s viral like
it'd be fascinating like Masters of the
Universe is a good example like Howard
the Duck too where there was there was
already like a weird cultural
Fascination around it but that would
have just been magnified a thousand
times especially with George Lucas's
name on it uh yeah I can only imagine
what Howard the Duck would it's like the
if like the Warriors came out in a world
with like cosplay and like people people
were doing that that would have been
great that's seven more of us I would
say that like Duck titties would have
trended yeah yeah that's like the
Garbage Pail Kids oh my God imagine some
of this crazy gun so 80s Cinema dream
drought today yeah uh let's let's leave
you guys with this sorry I'm making you
work so much for uh uh on the spot but
daisu psychoro is asking us to do our
our ideal animal and vehicle combination
um
yeah
we've seen Snakes on a Plane so you
would ideally want to do blank on a
blank on a blank yeah
uh uh let me see I I feel like raccoons
on a rocket
oh
I like that it's it's alliterative too I
definitely wanted to be people are stuck
in the underground Tesla hyperloop
tunnel yeah trying to think of what the
best what animal you want to do stick
them down I I almost feel like I mean I
think
one tiger or something yeah that's what
I was gonna say it's like a magic Act
full of animals down at that tunnel
um yeah yeah you gotta get the Circus
Circus it's the circus a tiger a bear
that's riding around on a little cart
and like what like one other animal in
the Tesla hyperloop smoking monkey or
something with like yeah
we're under the strip they can't get up
we're stuck in the hyperloop tunnel Elon
Musk is there for some reason and they
just unleash those babies like well no I
think
it's Elon Musk is the one who released
the Tigers and shut it down because
somebody was about to I don't know uh
file a lawsuit or something like that
whistleblowers down there yeah yeah you
nailed it we already we we cracked the
story yeah and so uh I was just gonna
say chimps on a blimp so that's because
yeah all right uh we uh we're done we're
done here we're done the Snakes on a
Plane it doesn't deserve any more of our
time our attention or thought if you
want to keep it on the background it's
fine for uh for a movie like that but
next week hopefully something that is
campy something that is occasionally
scary maybe uh it's got some action in
it and um we'll maybe make you laugh
um and maybe maybe be a better time at
the theater uh I'm only halfway through
it but so far so good already uh already
a sequel so with some a sequel must have
enjoyed it there's already sequel has
been green lit so yeah action comedy
horror you could say it's a triple
threat so we'll see uh we'll see you
next week for honest trailer
commentaries thanks so much for watching
bye
[Music]